oh yeah I want to say about did you ever
know because this is in your timeframe
because this is in when you when I saw
you around uh-huh I might have been
younger but that dude that claimed that
he was Eddie Murphy's son
oh yeah Brando Murphy write the story
but tell me about Brando Murphy so that
guy he was running around him and
Richard Pryor's real son
that's right around doing a tour
together and this guy named Brando
Murphy he was saying that he was Eddie
Murphy's son he acted just like any man
yet he had his laughs mmm-hmm hit Eddie
you eat physically yeah get on almost
like not exactly a Murphy but you
wouldn't not doubt it in your mind think
I could buy that and then huge as a
performer he was new but he was okay
right on stage yeah yeah he could sell
that he was new but he's Eddie Murphy's
kid brandão and I I got to the point
where I went to the Laugh Factory with
him mm-hmm
and I introduced him to Jamie Masada and
oh [ __ ] how did everyone find out it was
and Jamie put him up yeah I love it I
love it he's my friend
yeah that's what he said and then I
found out that Eddie Murphy sued him
right yeah
wait how did okay so that's how everyone
found out this because of the lawsuit he
got big they got big and then I saw him
right by our new house at that Starbucks
yeah go ahead George tell people were
the [ __ ] we live you don't know what
that's worth a [ __ ] Starbucks exactly
where that is exactly house is from
adjacent to that all right I know the
area yeah no we live in now God George
but that good I've been telling
anyway so what I was not even saying oh
yeah so I'm at that Starbucks and this
is maybe a year after Eddie Murphy sued
him I saw him mmm and he came up to me
at notebook he was writing mm-hmm and he
goes hey man what's up and I looked at
him and I just went back down to
whatever I was doing ooh
and he never I never saw him again can I
tell you a story about that yeah yeah
okay so you met him after he was Eddie
Murphy's son all right yeah I met him
before he was in what him in was just
right when he was just Brandon Robinson
oh no I met him in the Laugh Factory
open mic line
no cool he was he was he was just
another young black kid or whatever yeah
you know okay cool this guy's friend had
his number and everything he went by
Brandon Robinson Brandon Robinson mm-hmm
if you're listening Brandon I want us to
be honest with you when I saw you
perform aside from the whole eddie
murphy thing in no way in my head I'm
like if this kid even in retrospect
wanted to do stand-up
just put the time in you have yeah all
the things tools you're you know
relatively young attractive you know the
right color great personality nice and
he could have done it but did he stay
friends with Richard Pryor's priors kids
um I don't think so I don't think so and
but yeah and now I have an after Brandel
Murphy story I saw him he was wearing a
he was wearing a suit um he was wearing
a suit like oh they're all like sunset
in like Martel I saw him and I said
that's it hey man he was like oh hey
what's going on I said so it's not me
you still doing stand-up he was like nah
I was like what do you know now he was
like I'm selling car insurance and I was
like oh no yeah Wow
yeah but why can't you brando just start
doing it you think that okay do you
think that people have that great of a
memory to where he is completely
blacklisted or is there a way for him to
recreate himself as someone else or
their dad if you're good you can
override all that I mean and if he did
put the time in or whatever cuz he did
you know he was pretty he was kind of
funny you know yeah yeah I honestly
would be if he went up as Brenda
Robinson mhm and I saw a medical show
and I saw him doing his own act right I
would go you know what dude this guy
proved me wrong this guy [ __ ] did it
what does he looks like now did he
really look like Eddie Murphy yeah I'm
gonna show ya he did you think if I look
up Brando Murphy would come up his face
try to look I'm gonna look it up right
now Brando Murphy remember it's a great
first day and they were doing a tour
called the Sons of comedy tour yeah oh
[ __ ]
oh my god you're right it does look like
him
Yeah right that's not that nuts dude it
looks just does it look like although
Murphy Rando Murphy there he is there he
is there was a pic bro so when this guy
is on stage yeah and doing his dad's
laughs oh and you go holy [ __ ] this is
the next coming yeah I have to introduce
him to Jamie Masada I want to be the
first one to do it I brought him into
the store and we just a bunch of you
discovered him yeah yeah like because
that's right
wow so wow that's incredible